because so-and-so's in the audience some
casting director mmm or or that just
directors in the air that you're like oh
[ __ ] people tell you when those people
are in audience I ask yourself that
would [ __ ] me uh I I go to the cover
both I go any give me the comps list and
the guest list and they give it to me
I do it every show I go is there anybody
here and they go yeah actually this
these producers for this movie are here
to see so-and-so on there right before
you I want to know those things that's
how you always know cuz you always come
home and he's always like so-and-so sir
how do you know him do you see him in
the crowd this once this one thing
happened to me I had his I randomly got
an audition for the last predator movie
movie and I went into the audition I was
wearing some weird thing on stage or
whatever and I remember going to the
audition in that exact outfit I didn't
even know that the person who gave me
the audition was in the audience but I
just oh this is all you were to the same
clothes two days in a row yeah and then
so I a mess so I went out and I did my
audition but when I walked in there
alight there like I heard them say that
and I said who said the copier
wait a minute you saw me the comedies
that's why I'm in here you didn't I
[ __ ] you up yeah yeah no oh maybe
sometimes acting aloof mm-hmm and doing
the opposite of what they expect yeah
works yeah because that's how I got the
Steve Rannazzisi NBC pilot I fell asleep
in the audition the additional waiting
room this is I get a call Rena Xizhi he
goes this is before this is pre his lie
of 9/11 coming out about that which was
the funniest [ __ ] I know we talked about
honest run is easy right yeah he we're
friends don't cut it out but Ren Aziz he
goes dude we I poked it you know you
know NBC oh yeah he goes you know
they're making the new friends they're
trying to create a new friends you know
three dudes three girls but this time
shot in Chicago and it's single camera
and it's about hipsters and I go okay
and he's like they realized they hired
six white people and then they got fired
one of the white dudes and they need an
ethnic guy by tomorrow ago we're in
Chicago yeah you shoot tomorrow but you
have to read now down I go I haven't
slept it I played video games all night
yeah and he goes you got to go in now
please so I went in there I didn't read
it and I literally as a goof was so
tired I go there was a table like this
and I go can I sleep here and I put my
sides down and I put my head against the
thing and they laid there for like 12
minutes really yeah like would close my
eyes they were laughing so funny that
was nice thanks for that and I go and I
just read it real quick I didn't read it
yeah and then I left and then I insane
and then I'm on set the next day and
that was so good all right so I fly in
yeah and for this and who else is in a
Steve Howey from shameless it's a show
called again sure that we did yeah it
was called not romance it was a song
something is easy something romance but
the first so the first shot that was me
in the audience of my friends in a band
and so I'm supposed to be sitting there
right and there's about a hundred extras
and I have one line like go Steve or
whatever the line is right and so they
go action they did something and I go go
Steve and when they said cut I had a
hundred extras come up to me go I go I'm
on the show oh they thought you were an
extra then I was an extra I knew were
begging me like did I suck somebody off
how did you get that one line whoa I'm a
regular [ __ ] back up yeah you know
that's why you hate extras oh that's the
source the other thing about extras have
you so you know you have an exercise I
was on set and Al May I was doing a
movie yeah it was [ __ ] I was in New
Orleans yeah I do get on this [ __ ] and I
was like I'm an audition in LA and this
net and they go all right it's older
black guy he goes all right he goes he
goes you know I you know I've been a lot
of things too you know yeah okay and he
pulls out um he pulls out a paper it was
a paper and then it was a printed out
paper he opened it up and it was him it
was him moving I think it was like a
mover or on something but it was a
printed out picture it was color write
print it out it was yeah yeah this is me
on that show you know this was his
resume Wow he's showing something he was
on but it was printed out yeah and it
could be you know it could have even
been a print ad yeah right
not live-action or was it something that
he paused and took a photo no man it was
something that he printed out on a
printer on a color printer yeah it was
him it was all fuzzy I was like who the
[ __ ] is me they don't know some people
don't know you know when you're seeing a
show like any movie if some guy has two
lines and he gets shot and he dies
mm-hmm right that dude is with William
Morris yep that dude right went to an
Ivy League school and went through
training mm-hmm that dude auditioned
against a thousand other dudes there
just like that dude and beat them out
mm-hmm it's
hard I always think about I always watch
commercials and then I I was like man
whom like that guy is an actor and I'm
like he does the same thing that Denzel
Washington does this bounty commercial
the same professor yeah he does the same
you know what also I find in commercials
I said this commercial where some guy
was the lead and he was supposed to be
at a Verizon kind of a desk mm-hmm and
he's talking to some other extra but
then he turns to the camera and goes hi
I'm so-and-so right but he know I know
that he doesn't know the extra right so
they have to do fake dialog like mitt
like mouth it out head of mine he's so
yeah and I because the extras go crazy
for that oh they love it they go yeah
they go
so anyway I'm interesting you want to
say shut the [ __ ] up I just open your
mouth what are the rules when you do
that by the way are you not supposed to
actually say anything no but they do but
they do they'll come back so thank you
for coming at you that's nothing they
don't want your [ __ ] you say peas and
carrots that's right you know well what
is it watermelon watermelon cucumber
yeah they go say watermelon cucumber and
you'll get all that but you know what's
another trick they use that works hmm
red leather yellow leather do it so
check it out
sometimes when you're tongue-tied with a
line an older actor will go just say red
leather yellow leather to yourself mouth
it out but ten times in a row then you
do it and then you go into the line it's
[ __ ] perfect is it because it's a
tongue twister and everything is easy in
comparison I don't know I never thought
about it but I do it all the time
yellow the rebel y'all if you're ever in
customer service your waiting tables and
you get tongue-tied use that trick
no wait for you to say it in the middle
of serving somebody know what I do is
like you're approaching a [ __ ] table
right and you go and just say it a bunch
of times to yourself and then say your
[ __ ] thing would you like to hear
about our specials the cornmeal hash
cormier ha
probably